اذا نتحدث عن مشكله ايرلندا الشماليه
وبريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي دعونا
مشاهدينا نتحدث عن جذور المشكله فرغم
جغرافيه ايرلندا الشماليه الصغيره
مشاهدينا كما نشاهد في الخريطه فان
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لها تجعل منها حجره
اساس في مستقبل العلاقات الاوروبيه
البريطانيه من جهه والبريطانيه الامريكيه
من جهه اخرى ويعتبر ملف ايرلندا الشماليه
من اعقد الملفات في كل مفاوضات الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع بريطانيا بعد لما له من حموله
سياسيه وتاريخيه خطيره تهدد بتفجير الوضع
في الجزيره الايرلنديه من جديد فما الازمه
التي تعيشها ايرلندا الشماليه منذ فبراير
العام الماضي قرر الحزب الوحدوي
الديمقراطي اسقاط السلطه التنفيذيه التي
يقودها كاحتجاج على صيغه ما يعرف
بالبروتوكول الخاص بايرلندا الشماليه الذي
يحدد وضعيه الاخيره بعد خروج المملكه
المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد ذلك تم
تنظيم انتخابات جديده منحت الصداره هذه
المره لحزب شينفين الانفصالي الذي يوصف
بانه الذراع السياسي للجيش الجمهوري
الايرلندي الا ان الازمه السياسيه ظلت
مستمره دون اي حل اما السبب في استمرار
الازمه السياسيه فيعود الى ان النظام
السياسي الذي يعتمد على التوازن بين مؤيدي
الانفصال عن بريطانيا ومؤيدي الوحده بحيث
يحتفظ الحزب الخاسر بحق تعيين نائب لرئيس
حكومه الحزب الفائز وهذا يطرح سؤال لماذا
انسحب الوحدويون اذا من كل اجهزه الدوله
الاجابه انه بسبب البروتوكول الخاص
بالبلاد والمتفق عليه بين لندن حيث يرون
انه يخدم الانفصاليين ولا يراعي مطالبهم
لماذا يثير البروتوكول الخاص بايرندا كل
هذا الجدل الجدل سببه نقاط التفتيش
والجمارك بين بريطانيا وايرلندا والتي
تريد اي الاتحاد الاوروبي ان تطبق عليها
المعايير الاوروبيه وهو مبدا يرفضه
الوحدوي